everyone super stoked to be here I am
very happy to be back in the Pacific
Northwest I'm from Vancouver and I've
been in San Francisco and it's been
pretty smoky lately so we're going to
basically write a bunch of code day it
whoops I might just do that in node
anybody know what happens when you do
this it's pretty funny well let's say I
just want to see it's like it's a
terrible type of whoops I wanted to see
if my screens readable it seems to be so
Java scripts not so great at math we're
not gonna talk about that say we're
gonna talk about functions is anyone in
here deploying AWS lambda into
production today okay
quite a few right on so I'm down with
making this little interactive so you
can yell at me what's the number one
problem right now is serverless cold
start cold starts one anything else any
code okay all right those are those are
pretty good I we're gonna touch on both
those I I would postulate the actual
problem with services nobody cares
nobody cares so you can deploy a static
website today to just about you know the
entire Internet in a few seconds it'll
be available to just about anybody in
about 10 milliseconds you just github
pages you could use an epiphyte could
use surge and then the backend you know
nobody cares we we do these things and
and you know there's just there's
there's no real motivation for this and
I think a lot of people are getting into
the service world but they're wondering
why they're supposed to care and so my
job today is gonna be to try and
demonstrate to you why you might care
and I'm gonna do this in probably the
most in advisable way possible in a live
code everything so this might go really
wrong let's just hope the demo gremlins
are on mice
so guess kaj yes I can't see that and
not think commonjs
I'm gonna touch what's called a dark
file so this is how I'm building
serverless apps and the idea of an arc
file is that it's a manifest format a
lot of these service frameworks are
using Y amel and I'm not down with that
so we're just gonna do something else so
I'm using this project architect
architect which is this rock
I've been polishing for about two years
now
we're reaching into the Internet to grab
it from NPM and I know one of you right
now thinks I should be using yarn I know
it's okay if we over soon
I almost installed this great not bad
tuner eleven packages I love to reuse of
that so we've got this you know empty
node project without too much going on
oops
there's my arc file and there's nothing
in here because I've been dying yet so
the syntax arc is pretty simple you
define an app which would be a namespace
so I'm just gonna do CJ s and then you
can define routes and these are gonna
turn into individual lambda functions so
let's do that we'll just do one route
for now and I'm just gonna create this
locally so node six I believe shipped
this tool called NP x and NP x is pretty
wonderful because it lets you run
binaries local to your projects so
instead of installing like a global
binary and having it all over your
system and not being able to deal with
it you you you can just use MPX and run
these these local binaries whoa so I'm
just gonna not open my node modules it's
a bad idea so when I ran that generate
that create local command on this file
it kind of mirrors the file system where
I've get this HTTP thing and I've got
this function right here I'm sorry this
is
so let's just think this a bit smaller
okay so this function just says hello
Cascadia and I'm gonna start a local
sandbox and we'll take a look at that
great okay
so we're running one function locally no
big deal let's add another function just
to make this a little more interesting
so we'll go into the arc file and we'll
just do a get food
px great local my terminal is not super
stoked on this resolution so it looks a
bit funky that's okay
and we'll run the sandbox again great
oops
foo see hello world it's kind of what
you would expect okay so working locally
is a thing but really we want to work in
the cloud so npx create local tells
architect to build that thing to your
local machine with an in-memory database
so you don't have to have an internet
connection or an Amazon account to to
prototype npx create by itself will
generate two API gateway instances two
DynamoDB tables in this case for lambda
functions and it will deploy the whole
thing and then wire it up with an IM
role the reason we do two of everything
is because we want to have staging and
production environments out of the box
so this isn't something that you can
really opt out of if we're building
software today we want these isolated
spots where we can stage our deployments
through a development process a lot of
other systems that are out there kind of
make you do this yourself you inevitably
don't quite do a great job of it
it means systems are not quite the same
you end up having it
list when you're deploying to anything
because you might have to do something
manually and your environments not being
the same means that you have tough time
reproducing bugs if you have a hard time
reproducing bugs and you definitely have
a hard time resolving them so this part
takes like a minute
but there we go we're live and this is a
lambda function deployed at this pretty
URL ooh and if we look fou should be
live with that hello world so not too
bad that took about two minutes
let's get iterating on this because
we're running out of time so maybe I
want to you know play with the session
let's say so we're gonna add a route
called post count and I'm gonna go into
my index module I'm gonna add a form
I'll leave this here
I'm just gonna be that guy and totally
make a messy thing here so we'll post a
count yeah
totally that guy it's okay
it's a demo a lot of button type equals
submit and we're gonna add a method to
that great so that will post to a route
called count and we added count here but
we have a generator yet so I could
generate this live right now into the
actual lambda functions server thing
that we've deployed the API gateway
thing but we'll just do this locally for
now so the create functions in dem if it
is a fancy way of saying it can be run
and rerun over and over again it's not
gonna clobber anything it only creates
stuff if it doesn't already exist so
that's pretty quick we got that actually
let's take a look boot up our sandbox
again you notice that sandbox starts
super fast that's what you want no
waiting for builds great we have a
button if we click it we go to this
place called count Jesus not so
interesting so let's go take a look at
that count function you'll notice these
functions so far don't have any
dependencies they're just functions
which is kind of nice so what we want to
do here is actually redirect so that's a
status code of 302 and for a location
we'll just go home oh god I love the new
keyboard these Macs
we'll pop back over here oh my god this
keyboard okay
and that probably redirected but I
didn't see it because I'm old
let's see it'll pop up the network yay
so we're getting a 302 redirect and then
we're coming back home that itself is
not so exciting let's let's start
playing with State so one of the
problems of lambda functions is that
they're totally stateless by nature it's
not really so much a problem as it's a
feature but at some point when you're
building an application you're gonna
need a session state so we're gonna want
to get one of those we bundle a couple
of helper functions for this purpose
their architect functions payload is
small for this by the way so if I wanted
to get some state here I could do like
it's a weight arc that HTTP session read
we can log it here just to take a look
at it and I'm gonna say session duck
count equals count or zero plus 1 and
then we redirect back home and then back
on that home Handler and get index oh my
god it's keyboard
how many times a day do I have to say
that before I buy the surface book it's
getting closer every day okay I'm
digging this new Microsoft so same
pattern gonna pop open post count just
steal that line a code I know this is
pretty messy so close you so this is
gonna read that session and it's gonna
look for well actually you know what
let's just be super weirdos and let's
just dump the whole thing out and this
is like one of my favorite debugging
techniques let's just dump the whole
request now we'll dump the session let's
do both we can do both okay
I got a typo in here somewhere no
actually I just have bad syntax
highlighting good
okay so when we redirect it's gonna come
back and it's just going to dump a
session it's not gonna do anything else
whoops so let's sandbox this so we can
see the login a little cleaner great
oops
and session doesn't have anyone yet oh I
did something wrong you can see my
session state is not persisting cuz my
ID is changing sweet you gotta love it
when the demo gods come and get you
this totally worked like an hour ago
okay we're gonna do some live debugging
here I know what it is some this is like
when I lose my keys the only way I can
find them is if I tell my wife I lost my
keys and then I'm like oh yeah I know
where it is so I assigned this session
here but I didn't save it alright so I
what I want to do here is get a cookie
and I'm gonna say wait are HTTP that
session got right session and then I'm
gonna write that cookie onto the request
that was the missing piece helps to
persist things if you want to see things
persisted okay
and there we go you can see down there
our count is incremented Hey so that's
local though that's not very exciting
like let's let's deploy this thing so I
didn't create all these routes yet so
we're gonna run this again without the
local flag and it's gonna deploy it to
Amazon and we can we can check it out
there to see see how we feel about that
you'd think Amazon would be fast at
Amazon kidding yeah Amazon's actually
shockingly fast all the time what what
it's doing right now is it's walking
through that arc file and it's making
sure everything's in sync and it's
creating assets if they don't already
exist and so you know it takes a moment
because of looking at every single
resource in that arc phone and
generating those things twice once we're
staging once for production once you've
done that the deployments are actually
shockingly fast they these functions
because they're tiny little bits they
can be deployed in parallel which means
that if you have a whole bunch of
functions you're basically only rate
limited by whatever you're paying Amazon
so in theory it's infinite but you're
actually bound by how much room you have
on your credit card okay so that
deployed I Michael
oh that didn't deploy that generated so
we already generated that home rep but
we actually didn't deploy our local
changes yet so we'll run that and this
is a resolution thing usually that
progress bar looks actually that looked
kind of cool I'm here for it so if we
reload that exact same thing that we had
working locally is now running remotely
you can see what we get this whole big
whole request object and oh no it blew
up and I actually expected that to
happen so Amazon for whatever reason
when you deploy API gateway it appends
these these sort of funky URLs which is
annoying is you know you want to work at
the apex of your domain so the way to
fix that is to set up DNS another way to
fix that is to hack the URL so I'm just
going to do that real quick so you don't
need this function once you set up DNS
and setting up DNS honestly it just
takes like not long so I deployed three
functions there in four seconds which
was pretty okay you can you can
surgically deploy one function if you
want to and that was the post function I
think so we'll just deploy that one
great
we've overwritten that function so we
should oh I know I
I have to fix that form as well it's the
fun of live coding you get to you get to
be along for the ride and watching me
flail this that's how you know it's real
all the mistakes okay so this URL is
ostensibly the problem is this reading
okay for you back there okay cool
your JavaScript devs where we're used to
a little bit messy syntax I love it well
just deploy the whole thing because who
cares it's like two seconds difference
great let's test that
well not -
okay state yay
and oh count of one Kenneth to sweet
nut that's cool let's deploy that to
production and this will just take that
same code and basically just pump it
straight into a fresh set of lambdas in
a fresh API gateway and these things are
entirely isolated from each other
they're not touching each other in any
way you'll notice that cold start was
non-existent so something that people
brought up earlier one of the problems
of these things the cold start cold
starts not a problem if you have lots of
small functions the key is to be under
five megabytes is this pretty common
knowledge now because I've been saying
it for four years okay so well we got a
few minutes I'm gonna cruise through
these last few slides I think you can
now maybe see that there are reasons to
possibly care about service the the
function is the key here and there's a
lot of things calling themselves service
today and that's fine they can do that
but if you really want to like see the
benefits of this type of architecture
lots of small functions is definitely
the way to go and one of the things sort
of big anti-patterns a lot of people
have been doing is it'll take a function
and they'll put an express webserver in
it and I'll deploy that one function and
it's a really bad idea
and I know because that's the first
thing I did with our startup and it
worked for quite a while but the moment
that you deploy an express webserver in
one function the very first moment is
the very fastest that thing will ever be
because you're just gonna keep adding
code to that thing it's gonna get bigger
and bigger and slower and slower so the
key here is to break it up in lots of
small functions which I think you get so
it's cool LEM does have a lot of nice
characteristics people call this only
pay for what you use a hundred percent
utilization I don't know why we call it
that just call it the only paper we use
and and by the way what do you pay
well 1 million executions is free and
then it's like a penny for every million
executions after that and so it's not
free but it's very affordable lambdas
have a way better security model they're
locked down by nature they only execute
for a hundred millisecond increments
when they go away there's no ports to
scan you control the dependency packages
that they go and then they go away
they're stateless so each function can
also be independently configured so with
a monolith if you're setting it up
properly with i.m rules you're gonna try
and have lease privilege which if it's a
model at least privilege will be you can
do everything with a lambda function you
can lock that thing down very discreetly
so get request can only read that kind
of thing the big thing is that we're
only focusing on business value so a lot
of time gets spent on infrastructure
I don't know that this crowd cares about
that as much but I know the big
enterprises do so to me fast our
functions are lambdas or whatever we
want to call them these are
best-in-class
they've got fixed costs have got better
security and you just get faster
iterations as you can you could see
these things are so fast to deploy so we
have a roughly 150 lambda web app and
our deployment time is about 40 seconds
which is pretty amazing
so you can deploy these things in a few
seconds but you can also deploy them all
in parallel you can deploy them
surgically and this means that you get
more iterations and if you get more
iterations and you probably have a
better chance of fixing that bug or
finding product market fit or you know
building that next feature and speed is
kind of the key so you're your author
time is faster your run time is faster
you're your bug resolution is better it
seems like it's pretty worth exploring I
also want to put out there that we
should be a little more excellent to
each other there's a lot of people
saying that they have the right way to
do this and I don't know that that is
true but what I do know is the back end
is now yours
you can build all that stuff and you
really don't need these servers or
communities or any of it which is a
pretty big deal so if you want to get
involved in this
we'd like pull requests that is
definitely contributing but bug reports
are actually like please please report
bugs I had someone that met just a week
ago and they were like oh I had a bug
but I didn't want to say anything I was
like no it's like the worst like please
tell me feature requests are also
appreciated I don't have all the same
use cases as you so please let me know
and share what you're learning and
thanks very much
[Applause]